[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con aquí
entradas 24 hace una semana a la luna
nueva marcó el inicio del mes sagrado
del ramadán donde los musulmanes del
mundo celebran el ayuno los rezos
grupales y los festines nocturnos en
familia pero si bien en medio oriente o
en áfrica las medidas para evitar la
propagación del coronavirus son más
laxas los musulmanes de américa latina
por segundo año consecutivo celebra su
mes sagrado bajo estrictas restricciones
y confinamientos le preguntamos al imán
marg y el presidente de la comunidad
musulmana a media de argentina gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí hembras 24 y
cuéntanos cómo ha afectado la pandemia a
los más de 6 millones de musulmanes que
viven en esta región
ahora hasta la mar y con la pasta con
ustedes si en ese sentido no es tan
afectado que obviamente en el islam es
muy importante la vida social y también
los lazos fraternales por ejemplo cereza
cinco veces cada día en congregación y
esto afuera del mes de ramadán el
bendito mes del ayuno pero durante el
mes de ramadán en especial los creyentes
se unen también a la tarde para romper
el ayuno en congregación y luego también
la oración de la noche conocida contará
vi que también solamente se hace durante
este mes especial también se hace en
congregación y obviamente ahora por
ejemplo como en argentina por el
protocolo sanitario la cuarentena y
tenemos que suspender esas actividades y
en ese contexto obviamente falta y los
musulmanes extrañamos a los lazos
sociales los lazos fraternales o
simplemente compartir la fe y los
rituales en la congregación en la
comunidad con los hermanos
bueno y marwan cuéntenos latinoamérica
está sumida en una nueva ola de
contagios de coronavirus por lo que los
gobernantes de esta región han impuesto
estrictas restricciones que coinciden
con justamente este mes sagrado en qué
medida los bloqueos están afectando las
celebraciones del ramadán
así son varios actos por ejemplo por las
nuevas restricciones no podemos realizar
por ejemplo en el islam es muy
importante nosotros estamos cada día
cinco veces en congregación en una
mezquita en un centro y obviamente por
ejemplo por el nuevo protocolo en
particular en argentina todas las
ceremonias religiosas en lugares
cerrados fueron suspendidos y por lo
tanto obviamente tuvimos que suspender
los cinco rezos diarios se ahora la
ruptura de la sura en congregación se
ahora en particular la oración que se
hace a la noche que es conocida en el
islam como tarab y lo mismo pasa para
nosotros sería sagrado ese día viernes
donde nosotros nos juntábamos para hacer
al mediodía la oración en congregación y
tiene una gran importancia es ser eso y
obviamente también hacer eso tuvimos que
suspender pero lo que es muy importante
que desde el islam uno puede realizar
todos los rituales y todas las prácticas
también desde su casa e individualmente
entonces en ese sentido no lo afecta a
un musulmán para
usar estas prácticas individualmente y
cuidan descuidándose desde su casa
bueno en suramérica brasil cuenta con la
comunidad musulmana más numerosa más de
1.5 millones de fieles la nación es el
epicentro también mundial de la pandemia
como se ha vivido en brasil en la
población musulmana cómo ha vivido esta
situación y también en argentina que de
segundo país de américa latina con más
musulmanes
así a los musulmanes nos ha afectado
bastante creo que como seguidores de
cualquier religión no que creo que cada
religión
sin raíz a por un lado en el amor en tu
creencia en tu relación con tu creador
pero por otro lado tan importante
también en cada religión es tu relación
la empatía la armonía la armonía y
también los lazos fraternales con la
humanidad con los demás y especialmente
con otros hermanos y hermanas de la fe
en ese contexto a nosotros los
musulmanes también ha afectado bastante
la pandemia el protocolo el
distanciamiento y obviamente tuvimos que
adaptarnos y cambiar todas las
ceremonias religiosas a la forma virtual
por eso por ejemplo nosotros ahora
hacemos las charlas por formas virtuales
las ceremonias religiosas sean ahora
informaciones
charlas para los miembros todo ahora
tuvimos que adaptarnos a la forma
virtual y la única diferencia es y desde
en el islam uno simplemente puede rezar
desde su casa entonces él no tiene que
ir obligatoriamente o necesariamente a
una mezquita pues agradecemos al imán
marwan el presidente de la comunidad
musulmana amalia en argentina por estar
con nosotros hablando del mes sagrado
del ramadán aquí en la región es usted
gracias también por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 en 5 minutos con
volvemos más adelante con más
información
[Música]